[Musique]
en majorité l'hôpital accueille
désormais des personnes non vaccinées
selon le chef de service ces
hospitalisations aurait pu être évité il
faut être très clair il faut dépolitiser
le débat il ya il faut arrêter de
diaboliser en m'obligeant n'oblige pas
il ya une question sanitaire c'est le
vaccin marche réellement et tous ces
patients auraient pu ne pas venir en
réanimation si vous êtes vacciné si 90%
d'une d'une tranche d'âge se vacciner
que les 10% restants disent non moi je
veux pas vacciner parce que je veux pas
crever c'est bien parce qu'on leur a dit
on leur a d'abord et le gran de
propagande anti vax élisions été et
qu'ils ont être s'ils sont des victimes
aïcha est vacciné ses trois enfants sont
à jour de tous leurs autres vaccins mais
au moment de vacciner contre le coc vide
ses deux aînés qui ont plus de 12 ans
elle s'est longtemps interrogé en tant
que tête il y aura des séquelles on sait
pas ils sont pas
vraiment fait le test de ces vaccins
dans la durée on vaccine néanmoins deux
forces dans l'es11 vaccins qui sont
donnés aux bébés sur l'hépatite b sion
calcul il ya beaucoup plus de chance
pour un enfant d'être malade de mots
vides et d'avoir des effets secondaires
que de l'hépatite b néanmoins personnes
manifestent dans la rue contre
l'hépatite b et un mot du professeur
didier raoult bientôt à la retraite
l'université d'aix marseille et
l'assistance publique de marseille
annonce ne pas vouloir prolonger son
mandat de professeurs à la rentrée à 69
ans il a atteint l'âge de cessation
obligatoire d'activité certains y voient
une mise à la porte forcée après ses
propos polémiques mettant en cause de
l'efficacité du vaccin tu peux pas en
faire capoter ce matin ce qui me donne
des leçons de démocratie
à six mois je suis en dictature a fait
clairement donc je fais ce que je veux
tencent vient d'imposer tencent et le
géant chinois des jeux vidéo et bien
vient d'imposer une nouvelle restriction
sur le jeu le plus populaire du pays ça
s'appelle honor of kings pratiquer
chaque jour pas 100 millions de
personnes les moins de 18 ans ne peuvent
plus désormais y jouer que deux heures
par jour en période de vacances une
heure par jour seulement en période
scolaire au delà le jeu se verrouille la
chine veut des relations je cite amical
avec le nouveau régime de kaboul avec
les talibans la chine qui ne casse pas
sa joie que les américains mordent la
poussière en afghanistan si l'on en
croit la presse d'état qui parle de des
bacs voire de trahison envers les
afghans ce drapeau afghan sur les
épaules elles sont en première ligne des
manifestations de l'après-midi à kaboul
les femmes afghanes se montre par peur
de disparaître comme sur les vitrines
des boutiques ou sous la burqa le voile
intégral dont les ventes explosent déjà
est ce que tu crois les talibans quand
ils disent que les femmes pourront
travailler
non non ils montrent surtout
je suis allé parler aux talibans pour
qu'ils laissent rentrer une famille à
l'ambassade
charles qu'il m'a crié dessus en me
disant tu es une fille comment tu ose me
parlent et je ne parle pas aux femmes
c'est l'afghanistan qui est en top indé
vacances à risque voilà ce qui a amené
lord miles et un pseudo à prendre des
billets d'avion il y a trois mois pour
kaboul j'ai cherché des dix pays les
plus dangereux du monde l'afghanistan
était en haut de la liste de son vrai
nom maylis roques l'edge étudiant en
physique de 22 ans en angleterre se
disait tant que les américains sont là
bas ça devait être ça devrait aller ils
sont encore aujourd'hui des milliers à
vouloir fuir le pays
mais les américains pour éviter le chaos
les empêche d'envahir les pistes malgré
les avertissements du ministère des
affaires étrangères il atterrit le 13
août mais voilà pas de bol on connaît la
suite de l'histoire les talibans
s'emparent du pays des américains se
carapater notre étudiant est pris dans
les tourments d'un conflit géopolitique
qui visiblement le dépasse un peu
heureusement que les militaires sont là
pour sortir les occidentaux il a donc pu
prendre un vol et il indiqué hier être
réfugié à dubaï avec une centaine
d'autres civils vous vous demandez
pourquoi il ya un char ici de braga il
ya un problème moral non ya pas de
problème
je déposais simplement mon voisin la
gare attendait voulez dire que vous
amenez votre voisin à la gare en art bah
ouais c'est drôle comme véhicule non
samedi et dimanche
on est là pour s'amuser
ah oui d'accord ça se fait ça de se
balader en char en lituanie bien sûr ah
c'est vous qui l'avez
chipeau trop comment j'ai fait we have
aussi ses mauvais bonnes soirées
auxquelles j'ai pas les critiques assez
vite c'est normal vous a bien géré la
situation et rocambolesque le jeune
homme a fracturé la voiture de son ami
pour pouvoir y dormir c'est fait d'album
utiliseront venise et ça va c'était bien
ce petit tour en ne sais pas comment je
veux dire en chat oui c'est un trajet
sympa et puis c'est très très
confortable très confortable oui oui
évidemment
et puis on attire souvent l'attention
quand on est à bord on se fait remarquer
notamment par les filles du laus
il semblerait que jean luc et trouver sa
nouvelle muse
[Musique]
tu peux m'appeler rose ouest a tué
penser
un peintre débutants vient de débuter
dans l'art contemporain
et ce petit nouveau s'appelle hunter
byden vous avez bien reconnu le nom de
famille c'est le fils du président
américain hunter 51 ans avocat homme
d'affaires et maintenant peintre et
apparemment son nom de famille l'aide
d'un petit peu puisqu'il ya une galerie
qui va exposer ses toiles et puis
surtout les vendent à la rentrée je suis
un homme d'un ambitions belles voitures
ben may dans la chambre dans le salon
jeux tournant
je tourne
jusqu'à 430 mille euros pour une
peinture grand format alors voici
quelques oeuvres je vais vous laisser
apprécier les oeuvres de hunter baden la
galerie georges en l'air je laisse oui
mais oui il la galerie georges bergès à
l'origine de la vente estime que le fils
de joe biden maîtrise parfaitement les
formes et les couleurs ce qui est un
très bon début quand même pour un
peintre et il ajoute que ses toiles sont
pleines de sincérité et plein d'espoir
deux yeux
kelly
ses descendants ont demandé il y a
quelques années de
venir pleurer régulièrement
sur la tombe de leurs défunts parents
c'est à dire qu'ils vous ont donné de
l'argent il ya combien de temps encore
ok c'était il ya trois ans
les gens te donne quelques euros pour
pleurer de temps en temps sur les tombes
c'est une vieille tradition ici c'est
ici que vision lune depuis plus de 15
ans